[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
last season michigan state went 22-9
they will open up tomorrow against
eastern michigan currently ranked 13th
in the nation and their longtime head
coach tom izzo joining us
coach how you feeling feeling better dan
thanks how are you doing i'm doing great
but you had covered
how bad was it you know it wasn't uh
real bad but it was no joke either you
know i i listen to people talk about
how it just comes and goes it it took me
12 13 days
and uh i was uh quarantined for 11 of
them and then i just uh you know
never felt real real bad thank god but
uh
never felt comfortable either so i'm
glad i'm uh heading down the right
direction last two three days i've
actually been in practice yesterday full
go
plan on being there today and uh i don't
know i plan on being there tomorrow
so that's the game plan right now what
are the protocols there
for your team day in and day out we get
tested every day here
um we're in that antigen testing um so
we're
we're testing every morning at 7 30 in
the morning and uh
i think that helped because it helps for
the the contact tracing as far as the
spreading of the disease but uh
the virus but uh you know it's
uh right now we've had some kids that
had it early like in september when
school
started and we've been pretty covet-free
other than this
crazy coach you know and i think i will
do every pro
protocol that i could go through and
still happen as far as uh
fans in the stands will there be fans
no we're not you know uh most of the big
ten
i don't think will but it does go more
by state by state as you know
and uh so right now for us in michigan i
i think uh
the protocol here is there'll be no fans
in the stands
as far as trying to bubblize this season
or
you know what are we doing with march
madness
where do you stand on this of trying to
get this season in
and and doing it as safely as possible
well i'm big i'm trying to get the
season in and i'm big i'm trying to do
it safely as possible i'm i'm a mass
wearer myself
and yet it didn't serve me as well as
i'd hoped but
you know i think until we get to the
grunt brunt of it then
that is going to be uh get the young
kids to uh you know
who don't get us sick maybe but are
transmitting it uh you see what we're in
right now in our country and i don't
want to get into all the political stuff
because i'm not a politician
all i know is that uh i believe we've
got to uh
we've got to take care of ourselves and
worry about the people around us
and if we do that i think we'll be able
to manage it i really do
how do you get this message through to
an 18 year old
well i got one at home 20 year old a 19
year old i guess and i've got a
24 year old and of course i've got a 15
17 to 22 year olds every year of my life
in this job
and uh you know you beg borrow you steal
you
you plead you get other people to tell
stories you
you look at what's out there uh i scour
all places like yours and uh you know
when you guys have stories about
different things good bad and different
i just try to relate them because me
lecturing them
doesn't really do it but uh the nba has
helped me
dan because of uh the bubble they did
and i said if
lebron james can spend three months
without seeing his family or friends
um you know it's part of sacrificing and
sacrificing isn't a word
accountability and sacrifice i think
left the webster's dictionary in the
last couple years so
we've got to get that back a little bit
there's got to be a little sacrifice for
all of us
and this is how i try to preach it to
our players
how's recruiting changed a lot of zoom
just like i'm doing with you uh you know
can i sign you
i got one year of eligibility left yeah
but the gene pool is it's been shrinking
over the years
i know i know but hey your team last
year boy i'll tell you what you had the
best
maybe the best team in the country and
uh it was a shame it ended that way but
for us recruiting
has gone pretty well i think people like
hearing me on zoom better than they do
seeing me in person
because we've actually had a pretty good
recruiting year
you got uh imani bates he's given a
verbal commitment to michigan state for
2022
well i can't talk about any anybody who
has not signed okay so even a verbal
commitment you can't talk about somebody
okay ooh
don't make me violate no no no no i
don't want to get you in trouble there
i was just curious because it seems like
this uh this uh recruit a possible
recruit could be um
like a lebron james type of talent there
but when you're selling are you selling
to parents
more on zoom are you selling to the kid
you know it's been interesting the one
advantage i think we've had
in our recruiting right now is you're
dealing more with parents and the kid
compared to you know when you're when
you're allowed out and there's so many
people involved there seems to be there
is a
you know a posse of people involved in
this recruiting and i think this has
kind of caused everybody to home into
family
and it's uh that's worked better for us
to be honest with you and i think a lot
of people so
hopefully it brings things back in order
uh that would be great i think for the
recruiting process in general
where are we headed with college
basketball in the styles
in college basketball because i don't
know if college emulates
the nba or is it vice versa but where
are we with the three-pointer
um you know that philosophy shoot seven
seconds or less
is college basketball embracing that you
know it's been funny to watch because uh
i'm with you you know you watch you're
seeing these quarterbacks in the nfl and
it's almost like the nfl is starting to
embrace college
where normally the pecking order is we
do what the pros do and then it filters
down into the high schools
and uh but i i think there is more
three-point shooting in college i think
uh you know it's just the way that the
game is it seems like you're either
dunking or
shooting a three the mid-range game of
michael jordan and guys like that is
kind of disappearing
but uh i think you're gonna see the big
man come back a little bit i
i really do i i i don't think it's gonna
be all run and gun and shoot and
and that's how you're gonna win i mean
uh the rockets
you know weren't as successful doing
that uh you know i think uh
i think that the team that really i've
appreciated probably because i got
draymond there but
you know when you look at golden state
um
they shoot a lot of threes but they run
a lot they did to get the ball
inside and they're very good defensively
and i think that's what gets lost in the
shuffle everybody thinks it's just an
offensive game now
i think the lakers won because they were
very good defensively i think miami got
to the finals because they were very
good defensive
give me the player that you're you're i
don't say shocked that's not fair to the
player but you're really surprised that
what you saw in college
he's so much better than that in the
pros
wow you know uh you mean one of my
players no
no somebody yeah anybody you coached
against where you went
wow i did not see that coming like klay
thompson
i i did not see that coming i i i would
agree to that we didn't play against
clay but uh
you know i didn't see that i i hey seth
curry i mean steph curry i mean i didn't
i didn't see that coming like
what he's done it's it's fun to watch
guys
um you know i recruited the booker kid
and i thought he'd be a good player
but uh he's turning out to be a
phenomenal player you know it
it's fun to watch guys that uh you know
you thought would be good players and
get to be great players
and uh i don't know often that was a
tough question right off the
right off the go but i i think uh guys
that are getting better in college every
year
have a tendency to get better in pro
bowl every year and it's been fun to
watch
uh the resurgence like i i really
enjoyed watching miami this year yeah
they play so hard or so tough they're so
pat riley-ish
and their head coach bolstra you know it
was almost like uh
give jimmy butler a lot of credit he
reinvented himself and it was a fun team
to watch
but also i look at lebron and when i
talk to younger basketball players i say
always add something keep adding
something keep adding something the
great players keep adding
you know mike would take you down on the
blocks and jordan added that late to his
game
kobe did the same thing magic developed
a little bit better uh jump shot or
set shot there and then you see lebron
lebron has
is going to extend his greatness by
extending his ability to shoot the
three-point
shot he doesn't have to go into dunk and
and he's still one of the great passers
of all time and i always say look to
those guys
they kept adding and sometimes players
get to a certain level
and then they stop and as a coach how do
you get them to take that next step to
go you were great in high school
that doesn't mean anything once you get
to college and then when you get to the
pros
well i think what i've learned about
lebron or kobe bryant
um you're right they add to their game
but you know what they've added to more
than anything is to their bodies
they take care of themselves you know i
mean kids nowadays are reckless you know
and
and i think uh you know in in lebron
james
what he's done with his body and what
he's invested if you read anything about
him is
incredible i mean uh yes he's added a
jump shot he's a better jump shooter
but i think the two intangibles that
separate lebron james right now
is uh physically his body how he's kept
it
and his leadership skills i mean i i
watch different guys go to them
and they just become better players when
they're around him
um he has a way of demanding but not
being
abrasive i don't i don't know what he's
like when you're there but
he's his leadership skills so as guys
develop things
a lot of times the last thing they want
to develop is leadership skills or their
own personalities
uh you know i hear a lot from parents
well that's his personality
well you want me to change his jump shot
you want me to change his strength do
you want me to change his ball handling
skills
sometimes his personality is that what
separates the tom brady's or the
lebron james magic johnson was you know
one of the ultimate
leaders who makes people around him
better and that's a hard skill to find
right now dan
do you have that kind of green carpet at
home
now i just got it right here man and i'm
going to send you some if you wanted it
would go good with your
ensemble there that you got has anything
been thrown in that office before
oh yeah that couple of those chairs
yeah you know uh we're in the big ten so
we you know
ask bobby knight we throw chairs and
stuff but it's uh
it's been a fun office when i look back
it's i've been in this office now
21 years of my 25 and uh
a lot of great guys have come to it a
lot of interesting late night meetings
in this office but it's been fun what's
the coolest thing in your office
the coolest thing in my office jeez i
don't know
it's uh probably a picture of my parents
you know i i i miss my dad and i uh
i think of them awful but often but i
got a lot of cool things in here there's
memories and
a lot of guys that help make me uh who i
am so i get to be on your show
well coach uh good luck tomorrow night
uh more importantly the entire season
eastern michigan against michigan state
uh good to talk to you again coach glad
you're feeling better
well thanks dan keep masking up stay
safe and i'll look forward to seeing you
down the road and maybe one day we can
talk about that uh basketball recruit
that
could be coming in 2022. sounds good
all right thank you coach so as soon as
i said the name imani bates
i get to see coach's face like nope
can't go down that road
i didn't know with a verbal recruit you
can't even do that with monty bates but
uh
hey if he gets imani bates even for one
year uh
good for him